(mellow music)
- If you're gonna start drag,
the place you start is with yourself.
Who are you?
What's your objective with this?
Why do you wanna do this?
Drag doesn't change who you are.
It actually reveals who you are.
(mellow music)
Your kindness, I like a kind drag queen,
'cause first of all, you gotta understand,
people who gravitate toward drag
are sweet, sensitive
souls, who have uncovered
the mystery of our society,
which is, it's all a hoax.
Our society is a matrix.
It's all an illusion.
Don't become bitter.
That's the biggest challenge you'll have
when you get into drag.
(mellow music)
I don't care if you are in
the backseat of a tricked car,
or if you were in church,
or if you were on stage,
do not take your shoes off,
do not take your wig off.
That is my number one pet peeve,
and that is the rule for life.
Know that.
Let the church say amen.
(mellow music)
Don't spend so much time
trying to get people to like you.
It's really a waste of time.
If you're a kind person,
if your intension is kindness and love,
you have nothing to worry about.
And you let your tribe find you.
You find your tribe, you
let your tribe find you,
but you can't force it.
(mellow music)
The best piece of advice
I've ever been given
was given to me by my
tenth grade drama teacher.
I think I was gonna get expelled,
or something was up, but
I was really distraught.
And he said to me, "RuPaul," my real name,
"don't take life too
(censored) seriously."
Now of course then, I didn't
know what he was talking about,
didn't understand it,
but here 40 years later,
you better believe I know
what he's talking about.
(mellow music)